Transylvania,
it's like Castlevania with vampires.
Yes.
You heard that writes the lands where
Dracula was born is also the place of
one of the most significant separatists
conflicts in all of Europe.
In other words,
Transylvania.
Well,
it is the perfect place to make a visual
politic Halloween's special and yes,
yes,
yes.
We do read your comments.
We do know that you want to add about
Castlevania and I tell you what,
we are working on it.
It's going to be big.
It's going to be complicated and it's
also going to be worth the waste,
I promise.
Just sit tight for Catalonia,
but for now,
let us get back to Transylvania,
which is a historical region located in
the center of Romania.
Dislike being in Romania.
Twenty percent of its population doesn't
even speak Romanian.
Instead,
their mother language needs to be
Hungarian.
In some areas.
The number of Hungarian speaking people
rises to 80 percent.
This area where the Hungarians are,
the majority is cooled.
The CICA landscape almost every year you
can see the massive protests of Zika,
least demanding more autonomy for the
territory.
These demonstrations are celebrated in
the main cities.
Transylvania as well as Bucharest,
the Romanian capital and Budapest,
the Hungarian capital,
but let's hold on for just a minute
because things are more complicated than
they seem in facsimiles.
Don't want to have their own country.
Instead,
they wanted to become a special region
instinct of Romania with a very specific
fiscal system.
So the question here is,
well,
why does this cause so many problems for
a while?
All these demands creating such a
significant diplomatic conflicts as
well.
More importantly,
the question is,
what does the Hungarian governments have
to do with this?
Well,
don't worry because today,
well,
of course they're going to answer all of
these questions,
but as usual,
before we do all of that,
let's go back and take a look at the
history.
Hairy tongue.
It's like for centuries,
Transylvania,
it was part of the Kingdom of Hungary.
Back then it wasn't even a country.
The upper classes and aristocracy spoke
Hungarian and Romanian.
It was the language spoken by the
present.
Yes,
points in history.
Romanian speakers.
What you've been prosecuted by the
authorities.
We call this process the mega ization.
Basically these Hungarian rule,
they wanted to impose their culture at
any cost to is rs two grants.
Romanians were sort of hillbillies,
so you had a special love,
the stealing things and a bad sense of
personal hygiene.
In fact,
there was even a term to refer to these
Romanians.
They were called at Zurich and yell
view.
This literally means with a hairy
hum.
So during the 19th century,
the government closed radian speaking
newspapers and they even forced a lot of
citizens do change their Romanian name
to re Hungarian one just like this.
Well,
after World War One things,
they really changed the Austrian
Hungarian empire and lost the war.
And one the things that happens when you
lose a war is you usually lose a part of
your territory.
One of those parts,
well that was Transylvania,
which was incorporated into Romanian.
Suddenly these peasants that were
oppressed by the Hungarian ability that
they have power and that power,
well they wanted revenge and this is how
the first attempts to destroy the
Hungarian culture.
Well,
that's how they started.
it certainly wasn't an easy job.
Do not forget that despite being a part
of Romania,
Transylvania was the home of over 1
million Hungarian speaking people.
These people,
they were called the weeklies and for
generations they had been speaking the
language of Istvan Orkney,
but things they got a whole lot uglier
during world war two,
Hungary,
well,
they once again chose the wrong side to
ally with with Hitler Elb.
They took it back to their former
territories and struck back against
though you see wanted to erase Hungarian
culture in the country.
As you might imagine.
This helps to make the Romanians even
more angry.
Then in 1945,
well the Germans,
they lost the war.
That meant,
of course,
that the allies also lost and that
included the Hungarians.
So Romania with a brand new communist
governments.
Well,
they took Transylvania back this time
though.
They had an even bigger taste for
payback.
So maybe you remember this other video
where I told you about the dictatorship
of Nicolae Ceausescu if you've seen it,
you already know that the communist
Romania.
Well,
it was the closest thing to a European
North Korea that existed.
One in every 30 Romanians was a part of
the political police and so they
prosecuted not only those who oppose the
government,
but even those you dare to speak
Hungarian from one day to the other,
Ceausescu close newspapers and forced
those chilies to speak Romanian,
even in their own
heights,
major realization,
bad as it was forced a few Romanians to
change their names.
Romanization was the same sort of thing,
just on a way bigger scale,
but hold on for just a moment because it
still doesn't stop here on their path to
destroy even the last resemblance of
Hungarian culture.
The Romanian Communist Party forced
thousands of citizens do you set up in
the Hungarian speaking territories this
way?
Hungarian speaking became a small
minority in cities like or daycare or
Saturday morning,
basically the whole area,
the borders with Hungary came a Romanian
majority region this via all of this.
That is a region that did manage to keep
their language and traditions in taxes
alone.
We mentioned earlier,
if the so called secret lab
mania
steals from us,
so in 1991,
Romania,
it past this brand new democratic
constitution.
The constitution recognized the invite
to speak Hungarian,
but as you can imagine,
after decades of hate against Budapest,
those seekers will.
They were far from happy.
I mean fiscally Romania.
It's a very centralized country.
Almost all the taxes are collected by
the central government and then they
share that money among the regions with
a focus on the poorest.
Once this boots Transylvanian in a
pretty bad position,
that's because,
well,
they are one of the wealthiest regions
and so.
Well this is how a new political party
was born and that would be the
Democratic Alliance if I'm Gary,
eons of Romania also known as Udm.
All on surprisingly they want.
All the elections in the regions were
Hungarians are the majority so well.
What are their foundations?
Well,
basically they claim that Romania is
essentially sucking their lifeblood.
That money.
Yeah.
It's pretty much the same situation as
in Catalonia and their solutions.
You end this Romanian losing is
imitating the fiscal model or they'd
another Spanish region and that would be
the Basque country.
Unlike other regions,
the bast citizens don't pay their taxes
to Madrid,
but to their local government
collected,
the local government has to give some
share to the central government,
but the rest is to be managed the way
the local government wants.
So this was the system that was proposed
by the seekers in 2014.
Guess what?
The Romanian government replies,
well,
they said it was against the
constitution.
There are any constitution starts off by
saying that it is a sovereign,
unitary and Indian visible country.
Now,
of course this is something that created
a whole lot of protests and a whole lot
of different cities.
There were a referendum attempts and all
sorts of other symbolic objections,
and these are all things that really
just the Romanian ruling class,
manias ruling party threatens autonomy
seeking Transylvanian Hungarians with
printers and punishment.
Attempts that threatened the
constitutional order of Romania should
be punished with prison.
If you've been following the case of the
Catalonian separatists,
well this might sound pretty familiar to
you,
but hold on just a second because one of
the best.
It's yet to come.
Autonomy or annexation,
if any of you have ever been hungry,
I'm sure you might've seen someone
wearing this tee shirt with this map.
It represents the shape of hungry before
losing a part of that territory's before
World War One.
Yeah.
Even today in the 21st century,
a lot of fun,
Gary,
and keep dreaming about taking that old
empire back and among them you'll find
the presidents of Viktor Orban,
the Vladimir Putin.
You just
like the Russian president.
Orban is famous for prosecuting
journalists who dare to criticize him.
He has passed anti gay laws and he wins
elections with 60 percent of the votes
and of course like every year to Putin.
Orbin likes to rule not only his own
country,
but others too or bonds supports the
autonomy of the CSI.
Kelly's.
Alright.
I know what you're thinking.
Why does a president from another
country missed with the internal
politics of another?
I mean at the end of the day what the
seekers wanted just to have more
autonomy but without leaving Romania.
Right?
Well,
in fact they're senior citizens are also
his citizens
grants citizenship rights to ethnic
Hungarians abroad.
Yeah,
you heard that,
right?
All of those Transylvanian born
Hungarians,
they have two passports.
They have the right to study in Hungary,
and of course they get to vote in
Hungarian elections.
This last thing,
oh,
it's pretty good for urban.
I mean he's popular in suite of
Hungarian borders,
but outside he absolutely steals the
show.
Ninety five percent of Hungarians from
abroad voted for his party at the latest
legislative elections.
Meanwhile,
Romania considers these rights for the
seekers as a complete violation of that
sovereignty.
In their opinion.
If you voted to different countries,
you can't be loyal to the one where you
live.
All this means that diplomatic relations
between Hungary and Romania,
pretty darn complicated,
thanks to this open can use Romania as
an antagonist to his nationalist
propaganda and then Romania where it
gets a great chance to give some shit to
Hungary when it comes to European
politics.
So now this probably leads you onto the
question of,
well,
what's the European Union?
Think about all of this.
The truth is,
despite the Council of Europe writing
memorandums,
would they defend the rights of ethnic
minorities?
Brussels would never let Hungary when at
the end of the day,
Viktor Orban is like the Dracula
Frankenstein and Freddy Kruger of
European politics,
so as long as things don't turn ugly,
don't expect any position from any EU
institution or politician
is what we think our official politic
and now we'd love to know what you
think.
Do you think Transylvania should have
its own autonomy or perhaps this is
nothing.
This attempts by hungry to get some sway
back on that form it territories.
Well,
leave your answers in the comments
section below.
We would love to hear from you.
Meanwhile,
if you want to know more about the old
Romanian communist system and the
current Terrainian and corrupt system,
do not forget to click on the video that
appears at the end of this one and do
visit our friends the reconsider media
dot Com podcast.
They provided the vocals in this video
that are not mine.
I do.
Don't forget that we published brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hits that subscribe button and you
will not miss any posts.
And if you liked this video,
please do give us a thumbs up and one,
I wish you a terrific Halloween and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.
Am I this.